const vs. let vs. var
These are all ways to
define variables in Javascript.
const and let were
introduced in ES6
but var has been with us
since the beginning.
Let's go over
their differences.
const is for values
that never change.
For instance,
if I have a const Pi
and I said
equal to 3.14...
then if I want to
set Pi again to 1
Let me run this.
If you look over on the side
on the console, you'll see
uncaught type error assignment
to constant variable.
So I can't assign a constant
to a constant variable.
However if I
clear my console,
and then I changed this
const to a var
and then I run it again
no error
Just to prove that was running.
We'll add a console.log
And you should see a 1
show up in the console.
Now let's go over let.
let is for block level variables
So for example,
If I have a for loop
[typing]
and then for loops
are always in blocks.
Blocks are anything
with these curly braces.
let variables, you can see,
I assigned a let variable in the for loop
and I am going to
console.log that...
variable that's
defined with let
and as you see
if I run this
It's gonna say 0, 1, 2.
So it's locking that variable
I assigned with the let.
Now if I try to console.log
that variable
before the for loop
and then we try running this...
You can see there's
going to be an error.
Same if I take this.
If I copy this...
and then put it
after the for loop
And we would run
this again.
Let me clear the console.
I'm going to run this again
and you'll see that
there's another error.
When you define something
with let, it's only available
within the block
that's defined.
We are now going to
go over to var
and you'll see
how it's different.
var is for variables
available to the entire function
or if it's not within a function
to the entire program.
I'm just going to copy
this whole thing
and paste it down here.
I am doing this
with a CodePen,
but I set the keys to be
similar to Sublime Text.
So if I just
double click this i
and I press Ctrl+D
and so I'll select each i
and then I'm going
to press [the key] j
to switch them
all to j
Now this let,
I'm going to switch to var
because we're going to
define the variable j
with var instead of let.
Now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to
comment out this
console.log and let.
We're going to
run this.
As you can see,
even though this console.log
is below the for loop,
it's still able to log it.
Now if I take this
console.log
and put one before
the for loop
the other one is
after the for loop
so if I put this one
before the for loop
and run this again,
you'll see in the console
undefined
Remember before
if I assign with let, it said error.
Now It's showing
undefined
that means it knows
the variable exists
because when you define
something with var...
it will be available even
before the time that you assigned it.
It knows it exist,
but it hasn't been assigned yet,
so it's showing undefined
because j does exist,
but it just hasn't been defined
to any number yet.
So those are basically
the differences between
const, var, and let.
And in future videos,
I may go into
even more detail.
Thanks for watching!
my name is Beau Carnes.
Don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good.